and in terms of staying healthy couldn't
be more pleased to have on the rich eyes
and show the head coach the washington
football team one of our favorite guests
and one of my favorite people that i'm
lucky enough that i've gotten to meet in
my years with the nfl and the nfl
network he is the head coach of the
washington football team ron rivera how
are you coach
i'm doing well rich i appreciate that
thank you it's a true story
i truly feel that way and uh very very
many interviews i don't start with how
are you feeling but this is obviously um
a german question of you how are you
feeling coach how you feeling
i'm actually i'm actually doing pretty
well you know um i finished up my last
cycle of chemotherapy and radiation
treatment last week
i'm in the recovery phase of it where
you know you're hoping the medicine
continues to do its job and finish off
the
the cancer and hopefully uh when i get
my pet scan in january everything will
be uh
will be where it needs to be and so uh
what has that been like can you just
walk me through what a normal week for
you has been
over the last few weeks coach well
really
really what happens is i i get i get
five proton
treatments uh uh a week monday through
friday
um i got uh three cycles of chemo one
every 21 days
and so what would happen is um just
depending on the week
my chemo could coincide with my proton
therapy which really
really zaps you um and so really
at the beginning of the week those weeks
you know it it really is a battle
you know the positive thing that monday
tuesday are typically are game planning
things
um you know which the coordinators were
handling and then you know
working my way to getting out to
practice on wednesday and thursday or a
struggle
by friday i really started to feel
better
and then saturday you know i was able to
do my my my my duties
and sunday you know the way i needed to
have them done for the game time so
it it it was a struggle at times um but
i was very fortunate i had a lot of good
people behind me and and really kudos to
to our coordinators for the job that
they did during that period we're seeing
the video of you
walking down the hallway with your
caretakers celebrating your
your final treatment what was this
moment like for you coach
um it was surreal uh because you know
when you first start
you know it's that old saying is you
know we get caught up on how far we have
to go
as opposed to how far we've come and
that's really what it kind of felt like
with gosh i've made it i'm where i need
to be and
it really was surreal and and it left me
speechless because
you know they just didn't do it because
it was it was me they do for all their
patients that finished
um there was a little young man that
actually had had finished
he was a huge nats fan he's a huge fan
of the of baby shark
which was their theme a year ago yes and
so when
when this kid was was finishing up they
were doing the baby shark dance
and i just happened to walk in when they
were rehearsing it
and i started doing it with them so it
was kind of fun it really was
but it's it's you know hats off to those
folks that uh
that you know that are the caregivers
because they're tremendous people
they sure are and obviously humanity is
is is
suddenly becoming a little bit more lost
in our world these days
coach and you know just seeing these
videos and seeing
seeing you do what you've done it just
gives so much hope and inspiration to
to so many people uh but uh in terms of
a sub set of individuals in the world
that i've come across coaches are the
biggest control freaks i've ever met
what's it been like for you
to be in a situation where you you
really can't control it
at all very frustrating very very very
very frustrating it really was it was
very frustrating
um because you know there's so many
things that that that you
do as a head coach something you're
responsible for and i felt guilty
several times not being where i needed
to be as a coach and like i said thank
goodness for jack del rio because jack
had gone through this
you know with coach fox and and he was
he's been tremendous he really hasn't
you know not to mention that he's done
such a great job with our defense this
year i mean
you know in spite of all the things that
he's had to do in terms of handling some
of my duties
um you know leading our defense to where
we are right now you know in in the top
10 in a lot of categories
has really been yeoman's work so you
know hats off to having a guy like that
but
it's been so frustrating just because
you know certain things that
i see would happen and there's not much
i could do about it because i just
you know i'm i'm i'm dealing with my
situation
um but again like i said when you have
people you have
coaches and players that really take
responsibility that helps
no sure and i guess last one for you on
this um
but i i have to follow up what do you
mean by guilty you really felt guilty
about the fact that you i did i mean
really because you know i'm a football
coach like you said
you you want to be in the middle of it
you want to be helping your guys
you know and and and there sometimes you
just feel like
you know i couldn't give them all of me
you know
the things that i do and so that was
tough for me it was a tough pill for me
to swallow it really was
um and and that's kind of i i felt you
know i felt odd about
i mean i i you know i never thought i
would be a coach that sat
in a cart and watched practice and
that's what i did
i sat in a cart i watched practice
you know i blew the whistle from the
cart i mean that that was that was
you know instead of being able to walk
around and you know pat somebody on the
back and hey great job or
hey pick it up you know you need to do
this i you know i was just
i was removed from it and it and then
that became frustrating and
and and and i got angry about it and i
also like i said i felt guilty about it
and so uh from moving forward are you
out of the cart and basically the next
thing for you is your
your scan in january that's basically it
right now yes
okay yes what i have is um my i have a
weekly checkups my two doctors okay um
i'm going to see them um
but everything's leading up to the scan
in january obviously hopefully
everything is done
completely and then there's you know
there's no residuals or anything that
need to go back and taken care of
and so that's what we're pulling for and
so basically you're you're back to
focusing primarily on football
essentially right now yeah that must be
great it must be great it's kind of cool
now
it is it really is i mean you know to be
able to sit down and watch tape and
and and you know not worry about i got
my appointment here i got this
appointment coming up there
you know take this medicine take that
medicine you know um
i'm down to just taking one set of
medicines a day and that's it
and as opposed to you know having this
regimen that i had to follow and
you know i couldn't miss or or couldn't
be late on
um that i mean i'm telling you i i've
advised very you know like i said
i was very fortunate you know that we we
caught it early
we had a good plan i had a great team of
doctors well uh ron rivera let's talk a
little bit of football then and and some
of the football decisions that
you have had to make or you made uh over
the last several weeks and let's start
with the quarterback position
um how would you rate your belief in
dwayne haskins
right now uh i think my
my my belief in duane is is probably
somewhere
uh gosh i'd probably give it somewhere
in the 70s you know he's got a turret
storm
he really does he's got an nfl arm he uh
he's got a good release
he's got good athleticism but he's got a
lot to learn
and that's what i learned from my 11
weeks with him as our starter you know
we went through seven weeks of training
camp
he took every snap with the ones we went
four games he took every snap with the
ones
but as we were going through it one of
the things that i saw was he's got a lot
to learn
uh and then lo and behold we're in a
situation where i'm looking at
you know what's going on in the east and
i'm saying god we got a shot
so i wanted to put the ball in
somebody's hands that knew the system in
terms of kyle allen who had played for
me in carolina who knew this system had
been in the system for three seasons
and i felt that was the best decision
and that's what i did okay
and in terms of kyle allen here he is in
his first game and he gets hurt
and alex smith gets put out there i mean
what was going through your mind when
you saw him and maybe aaron donald's on
his back
coach what was that cool you know what
right yeah but you know but you know why
though because you know during this
whole process
alex kept asking for more kept asking
for and i was trying to you know i
wanted to
kind of gradually bring him along but he
kept pushing for more he kept pushing
for more
and so what happened was near the end of
camp it was like we threw him in there
hey get in there do this do this
and man he just kept answering the bell
so
you know so kyle gets hurt and i made
the conscious decision that i'm
going to stick with alex and let him
finish the game even though kyle could
have probably gone in if we needed to
but i didn't want to risk putting him
back in getting him hurt and he's done
so i thought let let's see what happens
and and and
again alex wanted this i mean alex was
ready he went out and he performed
yeah well i wish he was under better
circumstances right but he handled it
and and and i'm telling you
every day i see alex now i see this guy
that just prepares and gets ready just
in case
and what's what is dwayne haskins
relationship with the team right now
i mean is he it's been good okay you
know he
he's number three he comes in he does
some work with the scout teams he does
his work with the coaches he's in
meetings he's getting his workouts
you know it's funny i i benched the guy
and it's like everybody thinks his
career is over here in washington it's
not
there's potential there's an opportunity
because again the kid has an nfl arm
it's just a matter of him developing
remember everybody forgets
he played 12 games in college of college
football
and then last year he really didn't get
into the into the swing of things told
me near the end of the year
he didn't have otas he didn't have mini
camp he didn't have a normal training
camp
but i did everything i could to give him
11 weeks
as the number one and he did some good
things and i'm not going to die that
because again
he has the arm but with him i think it's
about development
and growing and that's what we want to
do this guy is young
this guy's you know he's got an
opportunity to develop and grow we'll
see what happens as we go forward
and what is the relationship with ryan
kerrigan and the team right now how
would you term that
oh i love ryan you know and i think it's
a good relationship i think ryan's done
a great job
you know and and i said this the other
day i said his play to production is
pretty doggone good to the point where i
made the statement we need to get him on
the field a few more times here's a guy
that every time he's out there
he gets he does something he's
productive this guy's had a great career
this guy's a legacy player here
and that's that's where i see him i
think this guy can help us going forward
and we'll see what happens and now we'll
see what happens ron rivera in this nfc
east that you know
uh you've got a shot uh if this week you
know you got the new york giants
uh coming up uh next up for you and
you know with a win here to go to three
and five that puts you half game behind
the bye weeking eagles
and you're flat out in the mix in this
stuff i mean
it's an interesting division wouldn't
you say coach i haven't seen
anything like it i went through that you
know i went i went through this in 2014
when i was in carolina
right remember we won that division at
781 you know what's interesting is
there's been three recently there's been
a team that was eight and eight
that won their division and won a
playoff game there was a team that was
seven and nine
won their division won a playoff game
and then there was a team that was seven
eight and one
won their division won a playoff game so
anything's possible you just got to get
into that you just got to get into the
dance
and so you know we'll see what happens i
mean again i promise you the giants are
thinking the same way we are hey we can
win this game man we're right in the
thick of it
so going forward you know you've got to
play your best football especially
against division teams
and how how good is chase young now that
you're you're
supposed to play that's right so i'll
tell you
he has a chance to have one of the top
rookie type of
of years like you saw with with the
boces i mean
this this is that kind of player he's
he's a guy that comes along
every now and then you know and and
again don't sleep on montez sweat i
think we have a real good tandem of two
young defensive ends
that really have an opportunity to make
an impact in this league and if we can
keep them together for a while
we can be a pretty good defense okay uh
coach
really appreciate the time um i'm
thrilled to hear that you're
you're well you sound great i mean you
sound like you're ready to go and you're
you're back and you gotta you got an
opportunity to make some hay in your
division
sounds great well i appreciate it rich
and again hey everybody get out and vote
as soon as this show's over
i appreciate that by the way and i
appreciate you saying that not right now
that you know
you understand i've got 40 you know 40
some odd minutes left so i appreciate it
coach
thanks for the call all right all right
rich be safe you gotta tyron rivera
riverboat ron rivero hey you watched all
the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here